what's one skill that a girl would have
to have or like trait watching yeah for
a man that would like what would he
value
not running you know what today's date
I'm just gonna say a bean Bee's mother
be his mother that's what men just get
out of this book listen
most delusional I've ever heard
him or in Italian
spec to say to a man that you're going
to be his mother I it's not where you
see like the modern feminism that ego
coming yeah like you you look at it
she's definitely because if you want to
play the mother then you must on some
level look at him as your son right
which is a disrespectful to do you date
men that are children